soy el segundo de tele hermano
y soy nacido y criado en una pequeña
ciudad costera en aquel araucanía de
llamada no imperial
no imperiale una ciudad en la costa de
la araucanía de normas de 40.000
personas
una ciudad como cualquier otra
con poco retail con pocos colegios con
gente según no sea una manera muy fácil
pero no imperial tiene algo maravilloso
sobre bill que básicamente funciona con
gente con muchas ganas de salir adelante
siempre dicho que quien hace de no
emplear la ciudad de las mejores cosas
mejore la vida
es como él nació en nueva york solamente
si gano imperial así es para mí
y
y en base a esto les quiero contar una
pequeña historia de básicamente todo lo
que partió hace 10 años y obviamente
nadie
imperial comunidad desplegando para
mucha gente algo que se denomina sea
dormitorio
esta última palabra para mí marca medida
y mi madre
y ella se llama mirna ella podría
denominar hoy día lo que sería una
emprendedora
ella se casó a leda 19 años y ella se o
se dio cuenta de que con esfuerzo y con
trabajo duro la gente voy a salir
adelante
ella siempre me comenta que a los 19
años cuando ella se gastó ellos eran tan
humilde tan humildes con papá
que ellos celebraron su boda comiendo su
completa de una cuadra de la iglesia así
humilde here
jenson de esto mi padre era chofer de
bus y chofer de bus mi madre un día se
dio cuenta que ella dando comida y
alojamiento a una persona ella podía
ganar en un día lo mismo que ganar a mi
papá en todo un día de trabajo fuera de
la casa
en eso mi mamá encontró una oportunidad
de negocio
mi mamá se dio cuenta que podía criar a
sus tres hijos sin tener que salir de la
casa sin tener que dejarnos de lado
y eso se empezó a llegar empezó a crecer
empezó a tener una espalda donde primero
atendía a gente que eran choferes de
buses auxiliares después constructoras
después forestales y después otras
empresas más grande empresa ingeniería
el motor y así instituciones de gobierno
y etcétera hoy día tiene tres hostales y
un hotel
pero todo esto cuando hay el empezó a ir
bien yo me di cuenta a los 13 años de
que ella no tenía tiempo para atendernos
a nosotros que no tenía tiempo para
dedicarnos a nosotros
y eso a mí con 13 años no me gustó
porque si hay algo que se sacrificó en
el proceso fue la vida familiar
y me di cuenta que si yo llegaba a las
11 de la mañana había 40 personas en la
casa que se llegaba a las 3 de la tarde
habían 70 personas almorzando en mi casa
que se llegaba a las ocho y media de la
tarde habían 60 y 70 personas almorzando
cenando en mi casa
si llegaba en la ida había alguien que
no era de mi familia y estaba sentado
nosotros porque la empresa lo había
dejado
año nuevo no estamos dando el abrazo con
alguien que no conocía aún y así
el tema es
que básicamente ya los 19 años tomé la
decisión de que yo nunca lo había
reemplazar a ella en el negocio familiar
y empecé a emprender
y empecé a emprender básicamente no
motivado
por la búsqueda del dinero no motivado
por generar un impacto en una industria
tampoco para agregarle valor a un
mercado y voy a hacerme millonario ni
por tener una compañía gigantesca empecé
a emprender porque quería huir
y empecé a oír empecé a emprender lo 19
años empecé a emprender
hoy día 89 años después
he tenido seis compañías digitales seis
compañías que han pasado desde
videojuegos educación plataforma de
e-learning empresas de desarrollo de
software
etcétera obligaciones móviles
y todas estas seis compañías que tuve
tuvieron diferentes fines
una fue comprada por inversionistas la
otras las que veré otras las de louis
otras las abandone
y en este proceso
vegano junto a mi equipo en el año 2010
me ganó el 75 que el evento
emprendimiento en nación más importante
del país en esa fecha
esto fue mientras que yo dormía en un
colchón inflable en una oficina en metro
los leoneses en providencia en santiago
yo dormí en un colchón inflable
entremedio de cajas de productos y
entremedio de escritorios para ahorrarme
el arriendo de un departamento
entonces empezamos a viajar empezamos a
viajar llegamos a corea del sur japón
eeuu ve a chile y seguir viajando
en estos viajes fue que llegué a
california california eeuu se le con
valley
y estaría en silicon valley era como era
como el sueño era el sueño de todo el
mundo o sea
imagínate de salir de una ciudad
pequeñita como no es imperial en la
costa la araucanía y llegar a la cuna de
la tecnología y la innovación mundial
donde ideas muchas veces ridículas
partían con unos fondos de capital
increíbles una idea de negocio partían
con millones de dólares solamente con la
idea
sin un plan de negocios sino un producto
sin nada con la por idea
y yo quería ir sobre mí
y lo empecé a intentar intenté 12 ppc y
en todas frescas
fracasé porque no tenía el equipo
no tenía los cofundadores no tenía
mis pares que tuvieran el mismo hambre y
la necesidad que yo
pero mi necesidad era diferente y yo
todavía no lo entendía
del 2014 en california en eeuu
conversando con inversionistas
y me senté con más de 300 inversionistas
en todos estos años ha empezado
y muchas veces pensar que en cada uno de
esos cafés alguien me va a solucionar la
vida
y no fue así
y el 2014 conversando con un
inversionista del buy me dice sergio
tu mamá a que se llega y yo le expliqué
a que se cambiaban el ig no tiene
hoteles hostales en la araucanía en
chile me dice cómo le va bien
a mí me da pánico abordar ese tema
a mí me da pánico conversar con mi mamá
porque ella básicamente yo le pasa a ver
como mi competencia
yo competía con ella
entonces de pronto es muy típico que las
mamás a uno van y lebron hoy y como te
está yendo
y el mundo del emprendimiento de una
montaña de rosa
entonces feliciano bien
independientemente estuviera durmiendo
en el suelo en santiago no escuchen
inflable
entonces este inversionista va y me dice
una vez que entienden negocio mi hija va
y me dice
pero pero tu mamá podría ser
inversionista de startups
mi hijo si mejor lo que ella gana y como
ella elevada ya voy a ser inversionista
de empresa tecnológica de emprendimiento
digital loco
y cuando lo entendí si ella podía voy a
hacerlo
y esto inversionista en california van y
me dicen sabes que el negocio que ella
tiene cualquiera de nosotros a cancele
con vale y nos gustaría tenerlo
cualquiera de nosotros que reponer el
dinero a un negocio sí
y en ese momento hice clic
tuve que pasar 78 años viajando tuve que
darle la vuelta al mundo literalmente
pero me cuenta que lo haya tenido toda
mi vida
entonces este inversionista más me dicen
que se conoce también en negocios en
otros gusta
no te gusta porque ves cosas que no te
gustan
no te gusta porque ves procesos que no
te gustan ya sea la administración el
ejecución o etcétera
yo siempre una de las cosas que más
recuerdo y que más me marcaron fue que a
los 3 a 14 años en invierno ya las 23 de
la mañana sentía como tocar la puerta de
la casa
y mi hija se levantaba y bajar el primer
piso abría la puerta y se volvía a
acostar
y eso siempre me marcó
me marcó el nivel de compromiso que ya
tenías eso negocio
y yo no lo entendía yo lo veía como
esclavitud
y es esclavitud a mí no me gusta me
aterra
porque ella se levantaba varias veces la
semana durante todo el año y yo no lo
entendía
entonces
una vez que entiendo esto con el
inversionista
vuelvo a chile'
toda la oportunidad conocer a un gran
equipo que vive en mi equipo
y puedo decir abiertamente que hoy día
tengo tenemos
la compañía que siempre hemos querido
con los clientes que siempre hemos
querido
con la proyección que siempre hemos
en lo que hacemos en goal.com que no
está estar el día de hoy hoy día estamos
ayudando a más de 150 pequeños y
medianos hoteleros en todo chile desde
iquique hasta chiloé estamos creciendo
hoy día para latinoamérica
ayudamos en problemas de administración
tenemos un software una plataforma de
administración el precio más accesible
el mercado tenemos clientes que nos
pagan desde 1800 pesos al mes hasta 6
mil pesos al mes
y estamos además generando observación
de datos para poder desarrollar
políticas pero turismos
así hoy día estamos ayudando no a una
mina estamos ayudando a un montón de
minas como mi mamá en diferentes lados
de chile y el resto de latinoamérica
lo que me interesa es el hoy día
básicamente es que muchas veces lo que
nosotros queremos está un paso más allá
de nuestros miedos
y difícilmente nos damos cuenta que se
va a tener que dar la vuelta al mundo
para darnos cuenta
y básicamente me gustaría preguntarles a
ustedes y ustedes de que están huyendo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]